we are learning what tax breaks Tesla is
expected to get for its new three and a
half billion dollar investment in the
company's gigafactory in Northern Nevada
now this new plant will build electric
semi trucks all right
now moving forward the tax breaks we'll
be using an existing 2014 law for
Tesla's initial investment this time
around they won't have to pay of the 330
million dollars in sales business and
property taxes so they are getting a
break there
Tesla says it also expects to get an 81
million dollar reimbursement in sales
tax the company says it will also hire
about 3 000 new employees for the new
plant at an average of more than 22
dollars per hour and we do want to let
you know that the government governor's
office of economic development is
expected to approve the tax breaks
during a meeting this Thursday that we
only learned how much it would be today
the head of the oversight committee and
the Nevada legislature Democrat state
senator Dina Neal is asking the board to
delay the vote for a month saying the
legislature has the power of the purse